here's celebrating women today and you
have been all about the power of women
especially in recent months what does it
mean for you to be here today I think
anytime women can get together and
support each other I think it's great
I gotta ask you about Kavanagh
everybody's all jennifer was already
talking about him where are you at
mentally right now because we were just
had our eyes fixed on you during those
hearings actually one of our reporters
tweeted I wish she had the real power of
being a witch right now I saw that that
was awesome I mean I've moved on and I
really think that we have to focus on
the elections coming up on November 6
and turn whatever anger we have inside
whatever frustration whatever rage we
have to get everyone to turn up to the
to the polls and vote candidates in that
are going to respect and support women
everyone was watching you and you've
just been such a leader through all this
what was going through your mind when
you were sitting in that courtroom Oh
everything everything was going through
my mind I really ran the gamut of
emotions I'm feeling hopeful from you
know a crowd of dr. Ford and and
survivors everywhere to absolute rage
and anger when you you tipped your
glasses down and I was like god Alyssa I
wish I was reckless it was I have to say
there was almost a joy in why she use
the force
we were like please Alyssa make it
happen I love this guy right here
we just had Kanye in the White House
with Donald Trump what did you think of
that interaction you know what I don't
even want to give it the satisfaction of
speaking about it because I feel like
part of the reason we're we're in this
situation is because media has actually
given Donald Trump a platform so I'm not
even gonna respond anybody who you're
excited in particular to meet or to
speak to today out of these honorees
just everybody just to be here to
celebrate and support hello ladies
there is an explanation you are the
chopped' once the most powerful trio of
witches charms the reboot premieres
Sunday are you gonna be watching it what
do you think um probably not I mean it
was such a big part of my life and I
feel like I lived it for 10 years so
yeah I mean I wish them well but how do
you feel about the reboot like exciting
emotional what goes through I have no
feeling none I hope they do well just
because they never want anything to fail
but it feels like a totally different
show than what we did so you know I wish
them I wish them all the best
[Music]